اعترف شخصان من فلوريدا الآن
بالذنب لسرقة
المتعلقات الشخصية لآشلي بايدن بما في ذلك
مذكراتها ثم بيعها إلى
مشروع مجموعة وسائل الإعلام المحافظة فيريتاس
مقابل أربعين ألف دولار للانضمام إلينا
الآن هو برين جينجراس ،
وأنت تعرف ما رأيناه بالأمس هو
ربما يكون الحساب الأكثر تفصيلاً حتى
الآن لكيفية كشف المدعين العامين كيف
حاول حلفاء ترامب استخدام هذه
اليوميات لتقويض حملة بايدن ، نعم ،
ويخوضون في تفاصيل كبيرة في وثيقة المحكمة هذه ،
لذا دعني أوضح
العلاقة هنا حيث أقامت إيمي هاريس
في فلوريدا  شقة حيث عاشت آشلي بايدن
ذات مرة ، يبدو أن لديهم
صديقًا مشتركًا وفقًا لأوراق المحكمة
وسأل بايدن عما إذا كان بإمكانها
ترك بعض متعلقاتها هناك
ويبدو أن هاريس استفادت بالكامل
مما تم تركه في دفتر يوميات كما
ذكرت مع شخصي  تسجل إدخالات الضرائب
بطاقة كاميرا بها
صور عائلية ، وهاتف محمول الآن
متصل به هاريس مع روبرت كيرلاندر
وج  أعدت هذه الخطة لبيع هذه الأشياء
لمن يدفع أكثر من خلال الذهاب أولاً إلى
الحملة الرابحة قبل بضعة أشهر فقط
من انتخابات 2020 ، وتظهر الرسائل النصية
أن الحملة أخبرت كيرلاندر أنهم
لا يستطيعون استخدامها بأن المواد يجب أن
تذهب إلى مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي وبالتالي  كان على الثنائي أن يجد
طريقة مختلفة لاتخاذ قرار بالتواصل مع
هذا المشروع الجماعي المحافظ فيريتاس
والاجتماع معهم ببعض
المواد هنا في نيويورك
وهو مبلغ أربعين ألف دولار هو المبلغ الذي حصلوا عليه
حتى من العودة إلى فلوريدا لأخذ المزيد من
الأشياء في مشروع فيريتاس  اطلب الآن أن
يقول المدعون العامون إنهم يعرفون مدى
الضرر الذي يمكن أن تكون عليه هذه المواد
في أيدي المشروع فيريتاس
رسالة نصية أخرى بين قراءة
مثل هذه ، فإنهم في عمل سطحي
وهنا يتحدثون عما هو
حرفيًا مذكرات ومعلومات مسروقة
ويحاولون إنشاء  قصة من شأنها أن تدمر
حياة آشلي بايدن وتحاول أن تؤثر
على الانتخابات كيرلاندر وهاريس
اعترفوا بأنهم مذنبون يواجهون ما يصل إلى خمس
سنوات في السجن  أو مشروع
فيريتاس لم يتم اتهامه ، لم يتم نشر أي
شيء تقول إنه يقف إلى جانب جمعه الإخباري
قائلاً إنه تم تنفيذه أخلاقياً وقانونياً
ولكن كجزء من صفقة نداء كيرلاندر ،
سيتعاون مع
الحكومة ، لذا ليس من الواضح ما إذا كان
هذا يشير إلى أن هذا  لم
ينته مشروع فيريتاس يا شباب